juni habt ihr euch mal die texte genauer
angehört von favorite ich denke ja
und das ist schon starker tobak
darum geht es im fragen lotte unter
anderem oder warum er denn ausgerechnet
mit carolin kebekus einer einem comedian
einem einer komödiantin kombinieren
weiblich auf jeden fall einen rap
zusammen gemacht hat das sind die fragen
wo wir mal wieder den gesalzenen finger
in die wunde legen mal gucken ob
wowereit so ja du weisst was das ist ja
sehr gut ich natürlich noch wofür du
bist nicht allein sieben rote ziehen
will ja wie viele muss ich möchte ist du
kannst alle ziehen du kannst nur ein
paar ziehen
man kann das vorher abdrehen aber ich
bin sehr dafür dass linkshänder die
können doch machen
was kann ich okay
auf meinem album ist ein foto von der
raf entführung von hanns martin schleyer
nachgestellt geht das nicht auf kosten
des entführungsopfers und seiner
angehörigen
habe der nachfahre nachkommen
ok also ist es ist schon so dass das
jetzt war ja auch raab hat es ja auch
mal gemacht
bei diesen mit dem start der
fußball der bei dsds mitgemacht hat und
dann nicht parat auftreten dürfte nach
der ausgemacht das ist denen sehr übel
aufgestoßen darüber vorher nachgedacht
oder ich habe mal vor dass er jetzt von
der familie jemand kommt sie was nicht
gefällt kann sein so aber ich freu mich
drüber nachgedacht wenn das so ist tut
mir wirklich leid so ich will ja keinem
so eine also ist eigentlich ein scheiße
das erste rate sache so natürlich auch
schon zeit vergangen so ich wollte auch
nicht darauf ein großartig jetzt es ging
hier halt auch nicht umher schleier sie
hat umfeld der gefangener von
unterwasser halt so dass es so kam es
halt und das hat eigentlich nichts mit
dem ding zu tun ist halt nur ein spieler
gute gab es jetzt schon ein aktionär
noch gar nicht echt ne
ja also müssen wir noch nicht so lange
draußen
bestimmt keiner kommt marco sind wir mal
gespannt was er wollte ich hatte meine
grüne zwischendurch nehmen ja auch mal
ein bisschen abwechslung wechselbad der
gefühle
habt ihr größter war nix das so
wie christoph alex frage
du bist bei uns einer der oft
gewünschten gäste wie erklärst du dir
das so meinte das egal das ist oft in
den kommentaren hier ladet marseille
wird einfach so bei euch jetzt ein soap
eben
ich bin halt ich bin halt drauf glaube
ich jetzt mal
und die leute finde ich lustig so kann
ich immerhin geben und ich bin halt auch
einfach ehrlich so ich gehe mal hin und
mache einfach frei schnauze und ich
denke das finden die ganz cool obwohl er
einen stock im arsch haben so da komme
ich einfach hin und macht die sache und
das finden die glaube ich ganz gut denn
ich das immer dass ich draußen sind
außerdem nicht in super rapper ja ich
habe auch echt coole fans auch nicht
immer gesagt scheiße da seid ihr ja auch
bisher auch einfach mal zu geben
trotzdem manchmal sehr coole fans treu
sind so und dafür bedanke mich auch
jetzt ganz kurz stoppen
sie fragen fast direkt auf die ich immer
mal antwortet christoph alex wilks
umwelt verpesten aber das lassen wir
liegen da verlieren dagegen sagen ja mal
gucken wer kommt warum gibt es eine
zweite cd deinem neuen album mit nur
vier tracks ist doch total unpraktisch
ja und zwar ist das so ich wollte
eigentlich einfach während wir haben der
doppel cd und euch verarschen
wenn du trägst frage ob friedrich wollte
eine lehre zu die rheinbahn argument ist
irgendwann irgendwann haben sie sich
dann auch das ist so auf der amazon
inzwischen sind ja auch 86 drauf dann
habe ich das ok auf der ist einfach eine
bonus-cd der tracks die graf hat noch so
das sind geschenke wie kommt eigentlich
das album und das einfache leben viele
tricks drauf einfach so bei amazon
edition intrexx einfach nur so also es
halt nur das war total unpraktisch aber
hat viel schmerz vergeht ist umsonst
okay also ich werde euch nicht für
sachen die er sonst sind also nicht ich
habe mich ja beschwert
diesmal
nimmt schon das grüne
und dann noch nie wurde das boot nähert
dann der rote zum abi machen ich meine
zum abschluss abschluss und gegangen
so 'was machst was macht dich so
erfolgreich
bin ich so erfolgreich eigentlich du
kannst ja offensichtlich davon leben
jedoch im moment bin ich mir schon schon
schon erfolgreich was macht sie so
erfolgreich ja ich tanze aus der ich
gehe ich mit der maske mit ich wollte
etwas auf es sehr schwer also man kann
lieber mit ziehen so und dann halt
irgendwie erfolg haben mit gangs damit
zum beispiel oder so aber ich sehe halt
nicht mit das mache ich schon bisschen
schwerer beim boxster was auf und
deswegen die fans auch treu weil weil
die bekommen bei dir was ihr nicht
woanders bekommen also die
einzigartigkeit ist genau richtig
richtig ja und sie sei dann die seine
schweinezucht auf seine fans und die
kriegen wir haben auch die fans hast du
bestimmst du ja nur die aber gut sie
verhasst ja das sorgsam konzert ist wie
gesagt ihr seid alles scheiße geht bin
ich auch sagen ich
bin ein spiel mit denen ja also das ist
eigentlich schade natürlich ohne die
fans wäre ich heute nicht hier woher
komme ich dann okay gut also entscheidet
ist jetzt wieder da raus gehen
ich mache ich bloß radikalkurs erleben
muss wie
ist die geniale idee entstanden einen
battle.net karolius auch zudem carolin
kebekus macht den rap album habe ich
gehört hat sie angefragt überall nein
ehrlich ja sicher habe sagte kebekus die
macht komme die ich bin doch auch ganz
witzig finde ich zwar nicht aber die
fans
also habe ich mich noch mit der und dann
machen wir mal irgendwie so was weiß ich
nicht kannte und das auch ein bisschen
komisch war dann werden battle draus
gemacht
ja genau so wie ich mich mit meinen fans
in beiden mich mit den anlegern ist hat
so ein ding was ich immer mache spiel
als spiel hier so das mache ich ganz oft
so auch mit kas gegen eine oft ruhe zum
beispiel ist dasselbe dinge so
ich war die katholiken dem ist nicht so
dann haben wir das video online gestellt
dann trat sie auf einmal mehr cds
verkaufen wenn man geld rausschlagen
also auf das was sie sind echte ich
dachte sie wollten rap album machen und
daraus ist ein track auf deinem album
geworden ich glaube ich dass auf meinem
album es war ja ich jetzt drauf aber die
hatten rap album ist genau das kann man
ja ja das kam mir gleich wissen wann ist
es bei mir auf der wohnung zu denen auch
stimmt das war bei jedem fall dass mal
aber trotzdem ist es raus jetzt kann ich
auch nicht mehr so cool ist auch gut
getroffen und so also ich glaub ich
irgendwie das ist echt cool so drauf und
ja vielleicht ich bin ein bisschen die
website und die mich im comedy bereich
könnte man ja doch mal drüber nachdenken
man will ja auch expandieren so ich habe
kein beruf wie er habe keinen bock auf
diese scheiße wenn sie die ganze zeit
denn nur scheiß fragen du lebst fast nur
wäre es toll kannst du nichts zu sagen
aber genau hinhört habe ich mich etwas
zu sagen okay also wenn man jetzt wenn
man jetzt mal ganz stumpf darüber hört
dann denkt man das weiß man auch die
ausdrucke ganz flache scheiße wenn man
einmal genauer sich damit bevor sein
dann merkt man nach guck mal da ist doch
was weiß man hinter die fassade okay gut
passt auch dann künstler was ist eine
botschaft
war was ist meine botschaft nimmt das
leben nicht so ernst auf jeden fall ist
für den vielfalt ist euch
lasst es nicht mit euch machen steht
über den dingen ja versucht ein bisschen
zu verstehen wie das funktioniert damit
ihr nicht opfer dessen werden
franzi mit humor lasst euch nicht
unterkriegen außerdem so ernst zu nehmen
ist glaube ich nicht so gut dass das
macht mich sehr sehr kaputt
ansonsten hab einfach spaß im leben
lasst euch nicht verarschen und wenn es
so viel ist zu viel da müsst ihr
ausrasten und regulieren ich danke für
dieses schlusswort wegen danke ich jetzt
christoph alex den super